Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
Let's go back to the phones at (617) 830-4750.
Why don't we go to our caller from
country code 52?
This could be an interesting one.
Country code 52 what's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Country code 52 or five 24
okay.
Yes.
Hello?
Hello there.
Um, hi David.
Ah, okay.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Who's this?
Oh, I don't know if you remember me.
I'm the guy that called from Mexico city a
couple of months ago.
What was your name?
I'll send [inaudible]
Santiago.
Okay, very good.
You might be calling in from a different number
because we didn't have you in the caller ID.
Oh, thank you.
Pardon?
Um, yes.
I just want to make a quick question because
I'm in a college break and, uh, I've been
reading about what's been happening in Ecuador
with the protests regarding Latin Marina's
presidency.
And I'm especially terrified that I, uh, there
is a probability, uh, off a presidency, uh,
with [inaudible], which try to perpetuate
himself in power.
And, uh, honestly I have some relatives in
Ecuador and, uh, I would, I would just like,
um, I would like to know what do you think
of the situation?
How do you think is gonna end?
I have no idea how it's going to end.
I've been reading up on it in both American
media, but also in Latin American media.
And I, I could not, if you said you've, you've
got a bet gun to my head, I have to bet what
happens there.
I truly have no idea.
These situations are like a tinderbox.
They're extraordinarily unpredictable.
And I, if I were you, I would be, I don't
have family in Ecuador, uh, but I would be
extraordinarily worried about what's going
on for sure.
What do you think is the most likely outcome?
Uh, well if I'm not mistaken, [inaudible]
Korea is prohibited to go and run for election
because he's being investigated by corruption.
If I had been mistaken, yes.
But, uh, he had the supportive of the indigenous
people, which are the ones that are revolting.
So, uh, actually letting Moreno was the vice
president of our friend Korea.
So maybe you could have some kind of a crisis
there in which he could, uh, go or, or have
some kind of a puppet, uh, Cora puppet over
there.
And, uh, if I don't, it's pretty bad because
I also read that he was hiding in Venezuela
with my daughter and you know, that does not
give me good blokes about the situation.
No, that should not make anybody please.
Yeah.
So listen, we'll be following it and I, I
don't know what's going to happen, but it
is, I actually have a, I'm worried including,
I mean, what's going on in Argentina also
is very bad.
Uh, Christina May be coming back, which is
very, very scary.
Um, it could become a very dark decade in
Latin South America actually.
Yes.
We have more center right in Brazil.
We have or been in Nicaragua and not getting
out of power.
Yeah.
I'm optimistic with Amarillo in Mexico, but
there a lot of people, especially what was,
what was, what has been happening with the
Supreme court lately that uh, with some corruption
scandals.
I don't know what thing, honestly, but I try
to be optimistic.
Yeah.
And actually, I mean, Mex Mexico is one of
the places that seems to be going in a less
negative direction lately.
A, uh, central and South America.
Yeah.
To some extent.
In some limited way.
Yeah.
Some extent.
Um, so, so you're in Mexico city, right?
Yes, I'm studying college in Mexico city.
Very nice.
Uh, I've heard it's beautiful.
I've never been, but I plan to go very, very
soon.
Yeah, I remember you, you said it on a video.
Are you going to go to some kind of Cancun
trip or do some somewhere or near there?
No, no, no.
I, I plan to go to, to, uh, to the, to the
Capitol soon.
Oh great.
Yeah, that'll be awesome if you were to come
here and, uh, it's your, our beautiful country.
Our, uh, our Mexico.
Yes, we enjoyed it.
And I love Mexico.
I love Mexico.
I love the people.
Love the culture, love the art, love the food.
I mean it's just fantastic.
Oh thanks.
Thank you very much man.
I really appreciate it.
And that, just a final question.
I'm so sorry.
Uh, I almost got to go.
You had a, uh, an ad with a battle in which
you were saying that you learned Italian and
you were learning German.
I'm eager to learn a third language, but I
don't know which third language do you re
do you recommend me to learn?
I would recommend Hebrew.
It's so useful.
So many people speak it.
No, I'm kidding.
Uh, I mean it's cool.
It's cool cause it's a different alphabet.
But, uh, no, I mean I would, if I were you,
I would learn.
Um, I mean like I don't, what do I, I have
no idea.
I learned French as my third language and
I love it.
French is also nice.
Yeah, that will be cool.
I'm also, you get, uh, to learn Latin in college.
Yeah, I wouldn't do that.
That sounds not the most fun thing.
All right, Santiago, I got to run.
I appreciate the phone call.
I hope to hear from you again.